[Music]
I'm back Garney O'Donnell with the smart
castle I want to give you another look
at what's going on on the inside last
time we were in the front of the
building now we're gonna be in the back
this is where all the weed token
drinking partying this is where the
greenroom is for all the you know movie
star action happens privately we're
gonna have two couches back here
cabinets refrigerators a ventilation
system for big cab you know get some of
that a toxic smoke out of here but over
here it's also our stores area to here
is the chairs for the smart castle now
what's special about this is that these
chairs came from the First Avenue
Playhouse they were given to us after we
did the benefit what's so special about
these at the these chairs were the
original chairs at the Playhouse when
clerks had their audition so there's a
lot of sentimental value to the USQ
universe the clerk's team and kevin
himself so I hope you guys appreciate
that we got a little bit of nostalgia in
here but what really is cool today but
or should I say yesterday is that
Middletown came here and inspected the
building and gave us our first and
second inspections for rough building
and rough electric
so right now I'm gonna I'll take you
inside and show you what's going on
today it's a little bit of drywall as
you can see they put all the walls up
all screwed baby so right now I'm gonna
just do a little quick demo for you guys
how we go how we roll putting up the
half inch drywall screw gun very
dangerous screws ready don't put them in
your mouth but I do all contractors do I
gotta stay three feet away from my man
Chris
now let me show you Chris Cortez here
it's the big man on site what's up
everybody he's hooking a brother up it's
an honor to be here yeah so we're gonna
come back tomorrow once they get the
rest of this drywall though we're gonna
do a little spackle and then some
sanding we'll show you how that thing
goes but we'll be back soon please come
back check us out all right brothers out
[Music]
you